hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast characterization and
application of the triple
immunodeficient r2g to mouse model
presented by lee comign a chief
scientific officer at biologics in vigo
i'm susie valdez of lab routes and I'll
be your moderator for today's events
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by Andy go in vigo
provides essential products and research
services for pharmaceuticals crop
protection and chemical companies as
well as universities governments and
other research organizations
before we begin electrolyte everyone
that this event is interacting we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on the green Q&A button located at
the lower left of your presentation
window type that question into the box
that appears on the screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
notice you're viewing this presentation
in a slide window to enlarge that window
just click on the screen icon at the
lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
click on the support button at the top
right of the presentation window or the
Q&A button and let us know you're having
a problem good news this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits click on the button at
the lower left hand corner and follow
the process for obtaining your credits
please join me now in welcoming mr. Lee
Kony I will now turn the presentation
over to him lead
thank you Susie it looks like I I have
controlled in let's just make sure I
have the correct presentation so thank
you very much for that lovely
introduction as Susie said I'm going to
be talking to you today about the
characterization application of a triple
immunodeficient mouse model which we
call our 2g2 so let me move on to the
first slide which traditionally is the
summary of what I'm going to talk about
and then I will talk about it and then
I'll be summarize what I've already
talked about and so I'm going to tell
you a little bit about the
characteristics of the 2g2 model and one
of these how its assembled and then and
this is kind of the main gist of the
talk really is I'm going to take you
through some comparative analysis data
of the RTG to model and and some of the
data I'm going to show you compares it
with with a model that's been in the
marketplace for a very long time the
nonskid gamma NSG nice and not because
I'm trying to suggest this you know this
is in any way to clear anything in its
gene I think because of the nature of
that model it's a very good model to use
as a control just to describe when when
we're thinking about and what the what
these cell subsets are within the RTG so
I'm going to show you some data of that
in in spleen and blood then briefly I'm
going to talk about some of the factors
that contribute to to the the
differential radiation sensitivity
between the RTG to model and the David's
or the Skip models and the impacts of
that radio sensitivity on experimental
design a lot of people have asked us
about collaboration opportunities for
this particular model so I'm going to
I'm going to talk through some of those
share some data that we've already
collected as part of those
collaborations and then talk about some
kind of next steps
of course before I get into that talk I
would get chastised by my marketing
colleagues and if I didn't tell you a
little bit about in Vigo and who we are
so for those of you who don't know Envy
goes a global contract research
organization that sells both products
and services into the into the
marketplace and really our kind of
mission is to assist companies achieve
the potential of their products in
improving human health advancing animal
welfare protecting the environment and
impacting upon global food security and
this is a this is a talk that's probably
a bit more geared towards oncology
research so it's probably timely just to
talk about our approach to partnership
with oncology development we work with
with companies right from kind of like
lead optimization right through to
commercialization and we have a
specialist group of scientists that work
with customers in providing some
specialized models to the marketplace to
enable you to be more kind of productive
in your in your drug developments we're
a very custom centric organization that
really likes to partner with customers
and and I think in navigating through
the as I already said this is a global
company where we based in on 50
locations around around the world
providing both research models and
contract research services that those 52
locations it's on five continents
America Europe Asia and the Middle East
and we've got clothes on 4,000 employees
now and we're a reasonably successful
company with with with pretty good solid
revenues so just a little bit first of
all about what we call our average
models and services business so this
provides animal models environmental
enrichment products as well as dietary
products into the marketplace and our
production laboratories and our service
the brokerage again a spread around the
world in North America in Europe in the
Middle East as well as as well as India
as I already said another site about
business a very important side of our
business is the contract research
services business and so this is a non
clinical research business serving a
number of a number of industries both
the pharmaceutical industry the crop
protection industry as well as as well
as the chemical industry and again we
have laboratories in America in Europe
as well as as well as now I'm pretty
sure nobody is attending this talk
wanting to have a whole host of
[Music]
marketing vendor material on the
background of the company so thank you
for listening to that for a few moments
and now I'm going to get into the the
main focus of here today which is to
talk about what we what we call the the
art to g-tube model so a little
background on it are two g2 stands for a
both a rag to and an il-2 receptor gamma
knockout so it's a double knockout max
it's a mouse that we we in licensed from
Fox Chase Cancer Center and it was
achieved by back crossing the il-2
receptor common gamma chain knockouts
mutation onto a rag to knock out max so
the background of this mouse is a
mixture of F c57 black mouse as well as
a 1 to 9 and you have a nice little
little picture of the next day as you
can see it's quite a large Mouse and
it's a fairly robust now see
it breeds very well it's very easy to
handle it's quite a placid quite a
placid Mouse for those of you who are
interested in a molecular dementia then
you have that to to delight you in green
there so in terms of the model
characteristics then when we talk about
these models being ultra the
immunodeficiency [ __ ] immunodeficient
what we're really talking about is that
they're deficient in T cells B cells as
well as NK cells some of that inner
attributes might be that they have got a
no circling complement and decreased
function and what we see with this with
this model is is it does indeed and I'll
take you through some data that
demonstrates that and we also see some
reduced leakiness and what I mean by
leaky nurses is seen breakthrough of
those cells as the animal ages and
seeing increased numbers of particularly
named cells such as NK cells now and
we've seen reduced evidence of that
compared models which does vary between
the background and we also see somewhat
less radio sensitivity compared with
compared with traditional skills mics I
will take you through some of that data
again later and this is just some very
straightforward growth of care of data
I don't really intend to talk to it's a
great deal the way you can see these
these most well weighing well over time
when you compare it and when you compare
it to similar G's and you can see that
maybe there were a little bit a little
bit bigger than those but within the
kind of error bars one of two standard
deviations
on this graph so if any a filly reversed
pretty large pretty pretty solid max so
in terms of starting to take you through
some of the characteristics of this
model I thought it'd be nice to start
just with the kind of normal things you
look at hematology
I won't talk to this slide in any in any
great detail because expectations you
wouldn't even see me with an ounce with
certain populations not doubt but we're
not really drilling into lots of detail
here about the particular immune system
subsets and so the kind of fairly
standard kind of profile there and the
same goes for the clinical chemistry and
just trying to look at the kind of
background here and 13:30 females around
about seven or eight weeks of age and
just collect this data and again the
plus or minus there's two standard
deviations fine you know it gets an
important point of this model is the
health state to some of them that these
these animals are isolated reared
rodents and all in vigo isolated weird
rodents and negative you can see on the
list here an additional listing
organisms video can provide animals
three of the quest and so the specific
needs that you have those then then
please please let us know we actually
when we producing these animals we
actually also have sentinels alongside
them that have submitted both
comprehensive health screening and
that's emitted quarterly from the
isolator in us and bimonthly
in Europe and all those animals undergo
gross necropsy microbiology parasitology
and various pcr screens and obviously
only the the immunocompetent sentinels
will undergo swollen your screening and
and in this case we've got some
ligaments that are used as sentinels to
explore that so I think now I'll start
getting onto the the data which is which
is the meat of the talk and I'm going to
talk a little bit about the so so I
guess the purpose of the experiment was
to evaluate the RTG to mouth line from
from Fox Chase and we expect it to be
profound immunodeficient in in both T
and B cells due to the the rag to
knockout and we also expect the the il-2
receptor gamma knockouts to have an
effect upon the the population of NK
cells as well as the ability for any T
cells as I already said we've compared
for ease of comparison with another
product on the marketplace the energy
match line and most of this data is is
is basically to evaluate that
immunodeficiency music silence an
intricate valuation and we've got a
couple of panels for both blood and
spleen where we look into some detail in
lymphocytes as well as as well as the
myeloid part so into the spleen cell
immunity Iping first obviously it's nice
to get large volumes
spinner sites and from these my supposed
necropsy so it performs a good
population of cells to analyze so that
this really slide here really just talks
about the markers that we use the number
and the particular cell types we didn't
yeah within the samples and it's
probably worthwhile saying at this point
that there this is massimino phenotyping
this is one panel that you could use for
most immuno phenotyping if you spoke to
two or three human ologists you could
get four seven nine nine ten different
opinions on what the best panel was to
sustain lice
so this is just to illustrate the panel
we can use and I'll walk you through the
gating strategy as to what we picked
here and what this shows excuse me the
next slide really I think I'm not going
to go through in any kind of great
detail because I don't think he's it's
useful and helpful really when we're
trying to understand this model this is
percentage data so what we've looked at
is the percentage of cells of different
populations within a particular gate now
of course if you're considering these
are profoundly immunodeficient animals
so the the these percentages are kind of
meaningless really and if you have a
small percentage of nothing there's
still kind of really nothing there so I
don't think it's a really useful way to
visualize these I much prefer to see to
see that the plots of the data to
consider how the how the data was was
acquired and then just to look at the
gates and some representative Gaetz of
different animals so that's what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna I'm gonna talk you
through the gating strategy just to
illustrate some of these things and so
this is I guess the first gate that you
look at and really you just want to you
just wanna
like your your single cell populations
which which is a two-way forward scatter
plot and and then we can do a stain that
means we can exclude dead cells so we
can we can we can exclude those cells
that absorb the dye and just pick out a
live cell population and here as well we
have a cd45 stains of cd45 will stain
all white blood cells so that's that's a
good antibody for starting with and that
gives us that total my blood cell catch
when we want to drill into some more
detail where we want to really find out
which particular cell types there are a
gating strategy obviously changes and we
have we have other antibodies labeled
with different Florida roads and then
again we can pull out our lymphocytes so
a lymphocyte population and it's very
easy to pull out with scattered gate
it's always a forward side skeptically
on that slide there that's a forward
insights got a gate and then we can
stain again with with two very specific
antibody is in this case V 220 which is
an antibody against it these are
targeted mice which is very good there
are others as well that are used but
this is a particularly good one for mics
and cd3 which is fairly commonly used
across virtually all Romanian species to
stain up T cells once you've done that
staining of course you can drill down
into the subsets of those cells in this
instance we haven't really drill down in
submitting to the b-cell subsets but we
are interested in t-cell subsets so in
this panel we've stained with senior age
which is which is a classic stained
sorts of toxic teen emphasize and seek
enticing form which is which is again
stained teeth ourselves we haven't
drilled down below that you can drill
down if you want more into the into the
into the difference Sydney for subsets
with maybe th1 th2 th17 etc we haven't
done that in this case because there
were so few of those cells frankly that
knowing what they were then they're not
going to be differentiated so again we
can drill into some some details on some
other cell populations this is a this is
an NK cell stain so here we've got we've
got two antibodies really the both stain
NK cells as you can see the anti cd3
three five weeks tank and the the CD 49b
is a very strong standing k cells so
having the two antibodies in there
allows us to look at a discrete
population of cells and what I should be
saying here actually although he is on
the slide its gating strategies or
obviously all set up with any new
comments animal visa is the spleen
so just to take you very briefly through
some of the data that comes out of this
this is our T and B cell populations so
as you can see you know wild-type which
is there which is what I gates were set
up on excuse me we see quite clearly
being T cell populations but but in the
both male and female are two g2 animals
as well as that control animal which we
wouldn't expect to see these cells in
you see very empty gates
and this is going to be a common thing
but I take you through now I'm going to
show you lots and lots of pictures of
empty gates where we would expect as the
empty notes just to illustrate this
model so we can see it's gotten really
no T and B cells when we drill down a
little bit more into our scene the eight
and cd4 cells again as you'd expect
because you've got no T cells there
there are no cells of that particularly
need the NK cells similar story our wall
type obviously we've pulled there
the worldwide population but when we
drill into our our RTG twos
you can see that those remedy gates as
well as the NH gene so Marmot cell
Marshall myeloid cells of another cell
particular type of interest and there's
there's a lot of interaction between the
adaptive immune system and the innate
immune system so it's also interesting
to look at these these cell populations
again this is the same as before we can
we can stain at the lymphocyte the total
the total white blood cells and look at
those and then we want to drill into
into some detail here what we've done is
we've excluded all those cells that
express both T and B cells so what we've
got here is both an anti cd3 and an anti
cd19 antibody both on the same floor for
silicon we can draw a game around them
but there was gates that are t and b so
we can effectively exclude all those
cells there are T cells and B cells from
egg eggs and that gives us a chance to
look at some of the cells of modern
images so this one mylord derived
presser cells as well as details and
macrophage again as we move these dating
strategy I'll talk you through those
kind of one by one so again for the
mylord derived suppressor cells we can
exclude all the T's and B's we do a CD
11 B+ stain which which we can further
delineate by adding a two additional
stains live 6c and a live 6 gene and
there are two populations of these
myeloid derived suppressor cells which
are which are both thought to
contributor to tumor progression and
these were identified
9 or 10 years ago and there's a lot of
publications and data about how they
specifically and non-specifically immune
responses and as I say but we can we can
we can characterize the the myeloid
sorry the the monocytic mdf sees with
the with the live 6 C stain and with the
knife 6 g stain we can look at the more
granular sitting cells so the ones that
are more kind of polymorphonuclear the
run of the ways of looking at this and
this is just one gating strategy
macrophages are also kind of interesting
to us and there are several ways to
identify and delineate none of which are
considered particularly great I think if
you're really interested in in
macrophage function you can do a kind of
functional assay again we're looking
here at two different types of two
different types of macrophage known as
sort of M 1 and M 2 M 2 at the
classically activated macrophage that
produced pro-inflammatory cytokines have
a kind of spooky burst and typically the
th one type response and the M 2 s which
are kind of alternatively a crack
activated by different routes again
responsible to some parasitic control
tissue remodeling tumor promotion and
new regulation and that's the kind of
top box there the box below is another
way of looking at it with that with a
with a classic mark of the macrophage
again widely considered to be imperfect
which is why it's nice to show too but
that's with an NF 480 stain thirdly and
the last point is he's looking at
dendritic cells and this is a this is a
stain which is an MHC class 2 and CD 11
C stain it's a pretty classic way to
identify dendritic cells white blood
cells that don't express little side
markers but
Express the MHC class 2 and and seen the
11 see some people do further divide
this inviting to be 220 positive CD lib
and low kind of plasma site or DC's and
be 220 C D 11 be negative which is a
kind of myeloid DC's haven't gone in for
that here but you've seen when we look
at the blood we've done a little bit
more analysis of that and the one thing
I would say about these C's is this is
DC's in spleen cells spleen and you know
these are the classic d C's that have a
lot of morphology that you wouldn't even
typically see in tissue you have to be
very careful when handling these these
these samples to make sure you don't so
again this data could be kind of seen as
quite dull because I'm showing you
really indicates again both instances
the mob suppressor cells are reduced in
the NSG twos same for the macrophage
looking at the kind of m1 m2 type
macrophages same thing when we when we
stain in the f4 80s so you can see sort
of empty gates there and then the DC's
again the same kind of picture there
you're not seeing very much in the way
of dendritic cells there certainly next
I'll very quickly take you through the
the mouse blood phenotyping as well
again it was slightly different panel
there sore talk you through the gating
strategy some similarities but slight
differences in the way we stained up the
blood obviously we have other cell
populations in the blood as well so we
have doing lift sites granulating cells
and neutrophils and the like so we can
have a little look at them and whether
there's any differences there
I won't go on about this started
actually find the percentage data I've
already said it's better to look again
so so let's get into that now
so again gating strategy the lymphocyte
panel stange live cells pull out the
lymphocytes and then you can look at
your B's and T cells and NK cells so the
B cells here we're staining with with 24
the T cells singing 3 and we've got
another double staying here at cd19 bt
20 stains so we can we can really
brilliant on on that b cell population
interesting at least only monologist
actually did this which is why
generation this data why he got so
excited about really drilling on these
big cells T cells same as before you see
these three positive cells and then we
can pick out the fours and eights as
required in terms of in terms of the
results we can see from the forward and
side scatter used to identify those
lymphocytes that both the are two g2 and
the NH gene mice both have diminished
neutral sites as you would expect and
then when we go into the to the T's and
B's again you can see diminished T cells
the odd hint of a little bit of T so
they've got another distinct population
and nothing that's really going to be a
functional T cell based upon the
phenotype and genotype at these animals
same thing with the the B lymphocytes
very much a diminished population and
again blasting through these quite
quickly now because because it's a
similar kind of story the the cd3
[Music]
t-cells diminished in all of those all
of those samples in all of those samples
tested and in terms of the the cytotoxic
T cells and T helper cells again when
we're drilling to that we can see that
then we have some very empty gates there
again so so we've not seen any you've
seen before positive T cells or cd8
positive T cells in the in the RTG 2 and
n hg n hg blood and again a similar
story with the NK Marcus we can see a
clear double positive in the wild-type
blood and clearly very much diminished a
weak staining in the RTG tube and
controls in terms of the myeloid panel
same kind of story really we can we can
pull out our non T's and B's as I said
before and then really drill into into
neutrophils monocytes macrophages and
drilling for some subsets on that so and
slightly different gating strategies
that I've showed you spleen we can also
look at at DCs and the myeloid DC's and
plasma cycloid DC's which is something
additional but that we've done on this
particular this particular stain in
terms of in terms of the results just
again very quickly we do see detectable
levels of neutrophils in both the wild
type and the RTG to which you know you
might expect to see some genetics at
this particular animal macrophages and
monocytes again a diminished population
but you can see
some some of those cells within here but
similar to what you would see in his
teammate the monocyte subsets present
against and drilling into the the
seagull in the positive monocyte subsets
again we can consider to g-tube it's
very similar to were very similar to the
to the NSG and finally the last couple
of slides just relate to the dendritic
cells and so again we can see the spleen
and Walt are glued together there as we
look at this and then when we look at we
can see some again reduced but but but
similar kind of levels turn to what we
would see next gene and then when we
drill down a little bit more into the
myelin survive a seasoned plasma site
I'd DC's and we can we can pull out
those those those those those specific
populations I don't talk lots about this
because it might get a bit dull but
there's quite a bit of controversy about
dendritic cells and many other cell
phenotypes and but it's quite a nice way
to kind of classify them as as kind of
myeloid DC's and plasmatoid DC's and but
this is kind of a staining that gives
you the kind of feels on what's
happening in there in the blood of these
mice so in summary and I'm able to
summarize again at the end the wall type
Mouse has has kind of all the
lymphocytes and myeloid subsets that you
might expect it to have the RTG termites
are profoundly no inhibition so so if
you animals have had detectable
lymphocytes from a static gate and even
when we when we saw cells those things
we expressed
or in Kmart is there anyone in normal
levels there's a possibility of seeing
some cd3 low thermal sights which might
be extra baiting from the bone marrow
thymus into the systemic circulation but
these weren't having the functionality
that as a same base from the phenotype
of the cell you get a lot of assign or
use when you're collecting a lot of the
Vince
so again DC is detectable my lord DC's
undetectable plasma SOI totally seizing
it in both the RTG and nhg macrophage
human blood will no significant
difference and neutrophils pretty high
variability as you'd expect with
possible error expression I'm then going
to move on for the last few minutes to
talk about some other work that I'm
characterizing this mice mismatch line
at the r2 GT national radio sensitivity
and this graph really just illustrates
the percentage survival of the RTG to
model and nhg mag mics that have been
irradiated a range baud rate and six
Braves the Green Line is the are to do
too if you can't see that clearly and
the grey line at the nhg so this is the
two great dose and as you can see
there's really nothing there survival as
as we increase the dose so we see the
percentage surviving animals drop off
with the NSG
[Music]
by day eggs all of the animals died or
one Moorabbin and have been euthanized
as we moved to six graves then obviously
you can see you start to see
a dip off roundabout under be no day 14
to 17 with with the RTGS EMS so I mean I
think you know really what that
illustrate is is a different radio
sensitivity between the two species
tested which can have some advantages
particularly engraft in the bikini
radiate these animals obviously that
much higher dose of the radiation which
can be helpful in grafting some
particular tumor cell lines and exploits
I've got some data from some
collaborations now on various tumor
great studies in the RTG to mice this
one was was Nexus Barnum in Philadelphia
and this is this is growth PDX in skid
and the RTG to Mike's using green so you
can see a pretty good tumor volume
growth in our TGG compared with the skid
mouse and then we move on to this one
which is performing live link growth
colorectal PDX
as in a graft in NH g an RTG to mice
which was performed by by an academic
partner and again the RTG to had pretty
similar tumor growth and perhaps a bit
less variability the kind of dark
colored red line the penultimate one
thing here is is he is amount B cell
lymphoma allograft
and again the r2d2 has has a very robust
growth of that 20 mousseline and finally
another example there over colorectal
allograft in the R 2 G 2 and again the
RTG gel is very fast tumor growth in the
in the CT 26 mouth line so those are
some collaborations that we've had there
were an awful lot still ongoing as as I
may have mentioned earlier or if I
didn't I'll be mentioning for the first
time now we launched this model the the
ax you are meeting in Washington in
April we've got 40 studies ongoing
evaluating the RTG to model in a wide
range of oncology applications
what would you under the table transfer
agreements the syngeneic models humans
in a graph models PDX models and
humanization studies so to summarize
then this information on the RTG to
model so I presented some growth curve
data which shows the RTG T model is a
little larger five to ten grams larger
than the knobs and nods at a similar age
the RTG two can tolerate double the
single dose radiation tolerance I've
showed you a lot of flow cytometry which
which shows that these animals are
comparable to energies in terms of their
levels of T's B's and NK cells and I've
shown you some very briefly some to
model data which showed a good kind of
tumor growth and survivability and I
think the last point which is really
worth mentioning it is really the kind
of robustness of this model in terms of
in terms of breathing and
handling and then animal husbandry but
this is this is a very easy manage to
handle it's quite a large Mouse it's a
it's a robust max it's a healthy Mouse
it's it's a pretty docile Mouse we like
to encourage that people work with to
use both males and females I don't have
a problem with advocating those I think
that has a great three hours advantage
that we're always keen to push in vegan
so I rather hope that brings me to my
knowledge misaligned which it does none
of this work was done by me this was
done by talented team I'd like to thank
some of the Amigo team particularly
great banished Kirsty Harper
Mandy horn as well as Jamie Nathan in
their their own alphabetical order and
Cheryl wilt and torment and Travis some
of my commercial colleagues this
presentation as well as Harvard
University so thank you very much paying
attention I'd be delighted to answer
questions now I guess based upon the
time we probably got time for the three
or four questions now so yeah there is
there is a Q&A box so I assume that I
can just open up that Q&A box and see
all this but a lot of questions have
come in and maybe work through these and
an answer some of these questions so
perhaps just randomly first question I
have some disease models out that I
would like to evaluate with this model
who should I contact to discuss
collaborations yeah that may well have
come in before I actually mentioned that
so but
as I'm ready down there I should maybe
go back that's like we're very open to
collaborations of all types so so please
do speak to us
Travis is probably your best point of
contact there so Travis Rothrock at
nba.com really lovely chap we delighted
to work with you on your needs on that
and again he can he can also put you in
touch with with the relevant people to
be able to supply so I apologize if that
was that was too soon have you performed
any NK cell activity assays with cells
from these mice it's a very good
question
there are many NK cells to capture to do
a kind of killing outside but as I think
maybe I meant to say or should have said
during the talk and I think that's a
good acid test meaning of you know these
cells so flow cytometry tells you so
much but really you're only using
lineage-specific mark to look for a
particular cell time I think the
advantage of a cell killing essay is to
really get a good idea of the
functionality so that is a great idea
not something not something that we've
done yet but we will probably do over
the course and okay maybe I'll just pick
up on one there and hopefully I'll get
the answer right someone asked what's
the lead time I'm taking delivery of
this model in Massachusetts as far as I
know
and again I've given you Travis's the
contact details dollars to team up too
much but I think we tend to deliver on a
Monday and a Wednesday so so essentially
the lead times have rained about two
days depending upon when you place
but again the commercial team and put
you in touch with the appropriate people
[Music]
I guess Suzy is it time to to close out
this now I'm very grateful for everyone
listening and there's an again there are
a lot more questions there which which
will maybe put together and individual
responds back to people some of those
some of those specific questions thank
you very much for your your attention
and I hope you enjoy the rest of this
quite innovative thank you very much we
thank you again for your presentation
who really appreciate it and thank you
lab roots and our sponsor in vigo for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through 2018 January they'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when those webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thanks for joining us we hope to see you
again soon